britannique ce sont donc les problèmes
intérieurs qui ont dominé cette
conférence de presse avec une révélation
de taille le président miteran est
favorable à l'introduction de la
publicité sur les radios locales privées
il annonce ainsi un revirement de la
politique officielle suivie en la
matière depuis 3 ans depuis la
légalisation des radios privées
reconnaissant ainsi selon ses propres
terme que la liberté accordée à ces
radios reste pour beaucoup une espérance
plus qu'une réalité puisque non
d'entreell n'ont pas les moyens de
survivre personnellement je pense que si
tout tout toutes les entreprises toutes
les radios libres qui se doteraient d'un
statut d'entreprise type PM par
exemple donc responsable de leurs bien
de leurs ressources devant en rendre
compte c'est normal qui auront le statut
d'une PME devrait pouvoir bénéficier
d'une publicité
la sagesse encore exigera que cela soit
pour un temps d'antenne limité temps de
minutes par heure il appartiendra au
responsable d'en décider mais
personnellement je vais dans ce sens